[Music]
Ally
Sean oh my God what are you doing here
you know I'm just visiting my old haunts
on the off chance I might run into an X
from 10 years ago how many of you
running to so far
[Music]
let's go think about what would happen
if you hadn't left all those years ago
I've been kind of wondering the same
thing
I haven't felt that free in
I don't even know how long Sean honey
Mom hey I
agree Jojo
hey what a wonderful thing for us all to
be here so thank you to the bride and
groom for giving us a reason to
celebrate to Sean and Cassidy
I need to see this through whatever it
is you mean like with you in the groom
I mean we can just call him Sean
hi are you still here if my being here
is making you uncomfortable no no it
wouldn't be very cool of me to kick out
one of Sean's oldest friends
[Music]
[Applause]
oh she was cool she actually reminds me
a lot of me at that age
or he like a nudist I was I have an idea
keep your eyes on the iPad Bradley pit
Campbell do not taste the naked ladies
gone way too far I don't know I don't
know what to do anymore
[Music]